like i when i heard that my the first
time my mouth dropped one third of freed
slaves owned slaves
and then fought for the confederacy i
brought what the [ __ ] where's the
where's this like facts coming from this
this is from thomas sowells yeah but
where did he get the fact from where he
he spent his whole career researching
this stuff
like this man i promise you you will not
find a guy
that
is
more like well
like this man has spent 50 years just
researching this [ __ ] i don't think i
want to believe that i'm not saying it's
true or not i mean it's not for either
one of us to say because we weren't a
[ __ ] life
but
i i i don't i don't even see how that's
possible when a lot of um
like if you're asleep you don't have any
money so how are you going to be a slave
owner yourself i don't know i don't know
do you think he just made that up
it doesn't be i don't think that he had
to have made it up but i think it could
be
a version of the truth that he's wanting
to go with